[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings where we
are counting down to earth day it's
going to be Saturday by the way and
we've got our series protecting the
planet we are investigating a growing
controversy in Western Arizona that
could lead to a reckoning over a scarce
Water Supplies you may be surprised to
learn that farms in that desert region
are growing one of the most water
intensive crops there is Alfalfa and
they're doing it in an area where there
is a shortage of available water Some
Farms are foreign owned and they are
shipping the crop overseas to Saudi
Arabia amid a backlash the state
legislature is now considering a ban on
most foreign owned Farms senior National
and environmental correspondent Ben
Tracy has our story
side of a western Arizona town called
hope and as you can see
there's no water
cattle rancher Brad Mead is finding it
hard not to lose his this was your well
this was my will and now you got nothing
nothing but dust you can toss a rock in
and it's it's gone
that's it he then took us here this is
the edgier land here to show us his
neighbor's land he claims they view so
much water that his well went dry and
that's all fun de Montes all of that
green over there that green is Alfalfa
one of the most water intensive crops
it's used as cattle feed and being grown
on these massive farms in the Arizona
desert
by Fonda Monte which is owned by one of
the largest Dairy companies in Saudi
Arabia so when you look out there and
you see all that green what do you think
I see money leaving America
I see water getting depleted it makes me
very angry La Paz County Supervisor
Holly Irwin has been sounding the alarm
about these foreign-owned Farms since
they began operating here in 2015. why
would a company from Saudi Arabia be
growing Alfalfa in the Arizona desert
because they've depleted their natural
resource over there so now they're here
it's illegal to grow Alfalfa in Saudi
Arabia because it takes too much water
so Fonda Monte bought vast tracks of
desert in Western Arizona on top of a
massive groundwater aquifer in part
because there are no regulations on how
much water can be pumped out of the
ground
so anybody can come out here and buy or
lease land and if you can put a well in
and you can find water you can take it
that's right
as climate change fuels devastating
droughts Arizona and its rapidly growing
cities are facing drastic cuts to their
surface water supply from the critically
low Colorado River system we cannot
afford to give our water away frankly to
any
Chris Mays
elected attorney general as we talked to
her at one of fondamante's farms we saw
a series of fundamonte trucks hauling
dried Alfalfa off the property and down
this dirt road they ship it back to the
Middle East to feed cattle so cows in
Saudi Arabia are essentially drinking
Arizona Water correct these pumps are
pumping water out of the ground that
belongs to the State of Arizona and
essentially it's being exported to Saudi
Arabia fondamante declined our request
for an interview or statement but what
it's doing here is not illegal in fact
the State of Arizona itself is renting
this particular piece of land to Fonda
Monte for just 25 dollars an acre it can
then pump unlimited amounts of
groundwater for essentially no cost
there's nothing to say except that's
insane so if this is so obviously insane
how did this happen it's a great
question CBS News obtained copies of
several land leases dating back to 2014
that give fondamante rights to more than
six thousand acres of state-owned land
and the groundwater that comes with it
the leases are signed by Arizona's state
land Department we asked the department
why it granted the leases but it did not
respond to our multiple requests for
comment most State officials in charge
when the leases were signed are no
longer in office it is a scandal that
the State of Arizona
allowed this to happen the state doesn't
even know exactly how much water the
foreign forms are using
and to these sweetheart water deals
attorney general Mays a Democrat made
canceling these leases a centerpiece of
her recent campaign so we'll go see some
land she took us on a state-owned plane
to see the Farms from the air I mean
that is a lot of green down there using
Millions upon millions of gallons of
precious groundwater she says canceling
the leases is an urgent concern because
groundwater in this Valley is supposed
to be the state's emergency water supply
during a water crisis this is water that
Phoenix is about to need we are on the
cusp of a potential water disaster in
the state of Arizona How concerned are
you about the future out here I'm
concerned Rancher Brad Meade sees a
water Reckoning coming and hopes the
punch line on the way out of town
doesn't become a prophecy you got to
have Hope and Faith otherwise we're all
doomed right for CBS mornings I'm Ben
Tracy in Hope Arizona
uh wow that's exactly right you got to
have hope yeah you gotta have faith I
believe that yeah I mean faith in the
legislature there and getting something
passed it's going to right this wrong
because 25 an acre I mean I don't 25 I
wish my own water bill here in New York
where we have plenty of water almost 25
we call that protecting the planet
that's with the the lower third there
says that's really protecting America I
mean water is a resource we need but if
there's no laws to protect that water
then what are they really doing wrong so
it starts with legislation right uh it
does start with legislation that's why
we have hope let's see if they can get
it done yeah attorney general's on it
there yeah thank you Ben Tracy it was a
good piece